Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
In this series, we often marvel at light simulation
programs that are able to create beautiful
images by simulating the path of millions
and millions of light rays.
To make sure that our simulations look lifelike,
we not only have to make sure that these rays
of light interact with the geometry of the
scene in a way that is physically plausible,
but the materials within the simulation also
have to reflect reality.
Now that’s an interesting problem.
How do we create a convincing mathematical
description of real-world materials?
Well, one way to do that is taking a measurement
device, putting in a sample of the subject
material and measuring how rays of light bounce
off of it.
This work introduces a new database for sophisticated
material models and includes interesting optical
effects, such as iridescence, which gives
the colorful physical appearance of bubbles
and fuel-water mixtures, it can do colorful
mirror-like specular highlights and more,
so we can include these materials in our light
simulation programs.
You see this database in action in this scene
that showcases a collection of these complex
material models.
However, creating such a database is not without
perils, because normally, these materials
take prohibitively many measurements to reproduce
properly, and the interesting regions are
often found at quite different places.
This paper proposes a solution that adapts
the location of these measurements to where
the action happens, resulting in a mathematical
description of these materials that can be
measured in a reasonable amount of time.
It also takes very little memory when we run
the actual light simulation on them.
So, as if light transport simulations weren’t
beautiful enough, they are about to get even
more realistic in the near future.
Super excited for this.
Make sure to have a look at the paper, which
is so good, I think I sank into a minor state
of shock upon reading it.
If you are enjoying learning about light transport,
make sure to check out my course on this topic
at the Technical University of Vienna.
I still teach this at the University for about
20 Master students at a time and thought that
the teachings shouldn't only be available
for a lucky few people who can afford a college
education.
Clearly, the teachings should be available
for everyone, so, we recorded it and put it
online, and now everyone can watch it, free
of charge.
I was quite stunned to see that more than
25 thousand people decided to start it, so
make sure to give it a go if you're interested!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!